prendre soin du sol de tout l'écosystème
ce n'est pas limitée aux petites fermes
aux petites superficies de grandes
compagnies s'y intéressent aussi pepsi
cola car guilde généraux mise ces
multinationales ont chacun annoncé des
objectifs en agriculture est génératrice
totalisant des millions d'hectares
les prairies canadiennes
le grenier du pays et d'une partie du
monde
[Musique]
la sécheresse historique de l'été
dernier a fait mal ici les rendements
ont reculé de 30 à 40% et on s'attend à
ce que ces événements extrêmes
augmentent en fréquence
si l'on veut produire pour la population
mondiale de demain il faudra que les
terres puissent mieux s'adapter à ces
nouvelles conditions
chez les lawrence on est agriculteur
depuis des générations
léonie et son père viennent d'afrique du
sud en 2010 est la famille achète une
ferme de bovins et de grandes cultures
dans la région de yorktown en
saskatchewan
la terre n'est pas en bon état épuisé
par des années de monoculture même les
pâturages sont mal en point
après la première année on s'est rendu
compte qu'on avait dépensé beaucoup pour
de l'engrais des pesticides et on
arrivait à peine à faire nous ferait en
travaillant toute l'année
alors on s'est dit il doit y avoir une
autre façon de voir les choses en 2019
il participe à une rencontre proposée
par un organisme à but non lucratif qui
enseigne aux agriculteurs les pratiques
régénératrice pour l'ia ni c'est une
révélation
wen c'était comme si la lumière c'était
fait ça avait tellement de matches c'est
ce que souhaite la nature gp si j'arrive
à l'imiter je prendrai moins de risques
j'aurai une meilleure résilience face
aux surprises que nous réservent mère
nature
la seule académie lots des partenaires
terrain du géant alimentaire john romero
la multinationale s'est fixé un objectif
voir s'implanter l'agriculture
régénératrice sur plus de 400 mille
hectares d'ici 2030 dans le monde elle
cherche donc des fermes pour un projet
pilote le fabricant de céréales
n'achètera pas directement la récolte
des fermes sélectionner les agriculteurs
ne seront pas rémunérés mais ils seront
accompagnés par un mentor
[Musique]
c'est le rôle que joue blender tasse ce
fermier compte 45 ans d'expérience dont
20 en agriculture régénératrice
le modèle industriel mis de l'avant
depuis 50 ans on me nomme la santé des
sols
chaque année elle se détériore et le
modèle est de moins en moins résille
l'un des piliers de l'agriculture
régénératrice c'est la diversité des
plantes cultivées
dans la nature on ne trouve jamais une
seule variété de plantes mais dans les
champs c'est ce qu'on voit et cette
année en particulier cette approche
montre ses limites
ici c'est une monoculture de canola elle
a été très affectée par la chaleur
pourtant dans les mêmes conditions météo
le même type de sol vous pouvez voir
derrière moi que la culture mixte de
poids et d'orge pousse bien mieux que la
monoculture de canola
et ce malgré la quasi absence d'eau pour
l'ia ni la preuve est faite elle ne
sèmera plus jamais de mono culture de
canola
[Musique]
dans le cadre du projet pilote de trois
ans plusieurs paramètres seront mesurer
et comparer avec des fermes
conventionnelle témoins comme la
présence des insectes et des oiseaux
ou encore la capacité d'infiltration de
l'eau
cela équivaut à des précipitations de 25
mm en 2 minutes l'on a été absorbée dans
le sol
sol conventionnelle moyens mettra dix
minutes pour absorber 25 mm d'eau
s'il pleut très fort les sols dégradés
sont incapables d'absorber l'eau qui va
rapidement gonflé les rivières
on peut faire beaucoup de choses mais on
ne peut pas provoquer la pluie entre
temps on peut préparer le terrain pour
recevoir les précipitations
si les sols en santé peuvent agir comme
une éponge et retenir l'eau ils peuvent
aussi servir d'éponger carbone grâce à
la photosynthèse les plantes captent du
co2 elles relâchent de l'oxygène et
emmagasine le carbone dans leurs tiges
leurs racines et surplus dont elles
n'ont pas besoin se retrouve dans le sol
et vont nourrir les micro organismes en
changeant les pratiques agricoles on
peut donc emmagasiné d'importantes
quantités de carbone ce qui fait dire à
plusieurs qu'une partie de la solution à
la crise climatique se trouverait sous
nos pieds
la plupart d'entre nous sommes
conscients que nous faisons face à une
crise climatique il en droit logique ou
séquestrés carbone se trouve sous mes
pieds les terres agricoles
bout nous mettons de carbone dans le sol
plus nos systèmes deviennent résilient
et puis à d'activité biologique dans le
sol donc plus de rendement et plus de
profits et à mesure que le marché du
carbone se développent il pourrait
s'avérer de plus en plus payant pour les
agriculteurs de séquestrer le carbone
dans le sol à plusieurs égards
l'agriculture est génératrice force donc
les fermiers à revoir leurs façons de
mesurer le succès financier
nous les fermiers sont payés à la tonne
produite
nous produisons de tonnes plus nous
faisons d'argent à l'hectare
mais il ya un petit piège ici
beaucoup de fermiers achète de grandes
quantités d'engrais chimiques
d'herbicides de fongicides et
d'insecticides pour augmenter les
rendements de façon artificielle
donc si on peut cultiver de manière
régénérative en misant sur l'activité
biologique du sol et en utilisant un
minimum d'intrants chimiques qui
deviendront de moins en moins nécessaire
à mesure que le sol retrouvera la santé
ont réduit grandement les coûts
peut-être qu'on ne récoltera pas autant
de tonnes à l'hectare mais c'est
beaucoup plus rentable est
l'objectif ultime est donc de se passer
de ces produits le plus possible les
produits chimiques les pesticides ne
font que traiter un symptôme et souvent
ils empirent
si des insectes pose un gros problème
dans un méchant oui je vais utiliser un
insecticide parce que je dois sauver ma
culture
mais le but c'est de comprendre pourquoi
j'ai ce problème
est ce que je pourrais rendre la plante
plus saine pour empêcher les insectes de
l'attaqué
notre qualité de vie la nourriture qu'on
mange notre propre santé
liés au sol
nous ramène à la terre
et où on n'a fait que si nous voulons
prendre soin du sol pour nous et pour
les générations à venir
le champ c'est moi qui m'en occupe mais
le sol n'est pas moi le sait ce qu'on
vaut pour produire puis c'est ce qu'on
va laisser aux autres pour produire
aussi même les artisans de la grande
entreprise
ils se rendent compte que nos sols se
dégrade et que ça pose des problèmes
pour leur propre profit
je crois que ça relève en partie du
marketing être versé à la mode
aujourd'hui c'est un élément positif que
des grandes entreprises pensent à la
régénération des sols c'est un bon pas
en avant mais il faudra pas s'arrêter là
c'est présentement la mode aller dans
l'espace mais où il investit des
milliards dans ciel on devrait investir
d'argent dans le sol pour comprendre la
microbiologie comprendre le
fonctionnement de ce jeune et moins
jeunes tous on devrait s'intéresser à ce
ses succès l'avenir de la planète
[Musique]